salut la jeune fille que je vais vous
présenter aujourd'hui est originaire de
la magnifique commune du quart des
communes qu'elle a quitté il ya quelques
années pour partir vivre en chine
laurie daniel nous raconte son parcours
sur la première salue le riz entre eux
trouvent en alsace ma la base tu vives
beaucoup plus loin parce que tu résides
en chine depuis quelques années déjà
alors tu as tu as dû rentrer en alsace
on va expliquer tout à l'heure aux gens
qui nous regardent pourquoi et comment
on s'est lié bien évidemment qu'on vide
mais avant tout comment est ce qu une
martiniquaise une carte des siennes en
plus je crois
ouais comment une martiniquaise se
retrouvent aussi loin parce que la chine
c'est à des milliers de kilomètres de la
martinique commencé oui je suis car les
siennes donc j'étais au collège l'écart
des unionistes et de paix l université
des antilles et de la guyane la
martinique et la décision donc avec un
master à poitiers et pendant les allées
d'un master j'ai donc décidé d'accoucher
et j'ai terminé mes études à
l'université de la langue qui est située
dans la province de 46 ans donc j'ai
terminé en faisant mon stage de fin
d'études et j'ai commencé à travailler
en chine pour un an deux ans au départ
c'est facile à apprendre le mandarin et
on a l'impression quand on entend les
chinois parlent x est inaccessible
toi tu y es arrivé c'est dur comme le
groupe iam à plusieurs en d'ailleurs en
chine à qui son parler le mandarin
restant la principale bien sûr c'est ça
au final si l'on retrouve avec des
pentes à chaque province moi j'ai appris
le mandarin
mais ce n'est pas pâti aujourd'hui
encore je continue à la rentrée vous des
milliers des milliers de caractères et
de mots qui se ressemblent et qui ne
veulent pas du tout dire la même chose
donc cela un apprentissage quotidien il
faut parler tous les jours pour pouvoir
continuer à regarder
tu travailles en chine d'ailleurs en ce
moment tu as dû quitter la chine on
comprend bien la situation était devenue
un petit peu compliqué avec le co vie de
la chaîne qui a été un des foyers de
départ de cette épidémie
j'ai eu la chance d'être en vacances
pendant qu'ils étaient en voyage donc je
pesais loto des états unis du mexique
elles sont bio etc
je suis retourné également martinique
pendant le mois pendant que c'était et
dénis auguin a commencé et j'ai vu donc
rentré en urgence en alsace comme cela
et donc on appuie l'addition de la
galerie et je n'ai pas pu rentrer en
chine sa trempe et la chine a
soudainement clairement ses frontières
avec seulement tu travaille dans son
coin en alsace oeufs dont le vent je
crois je suis triste et développement
des ventes des vins et les spiritueux
pour les supermarchés de la chine donc
l'ensemble des supermarchés chiffres
nationaux à suivre le travail on est on
est vraiment laurie admirative de ton
parcours c'est pas évident de quitter sa
martinique sont son île natale en plus
de quitter une belle commune comme le
carbet pour partir aussi loin en chine
il ya la barrière de la langue et à la
culture qui est différente
tu la fais tu as réussi à le faire
j'imagine que c'était pas évident au
début de partir est apte et des peurs
des appréhensions non c'est vrai qu'elle
ce n'est pas facile on se rencontre au
final pour mener en martinique a suivi
qui est normal contenus entre deux
clients de la martinique
on s'en rend pas compte qu'il ya
énormément de choses à l'extérieur qui
sont possibles soit on est un petit peu
attaché à l'équipe donc on a cette peur
de partir mais c'est vrai que c'est un
médecin également tels qu'ils n'auraient
pas s'il ya l'ensemble des martiniquais
pour leurs vertus devenu et qui on sait
pour l aventure ou à l'extérieur
si vous avez des règles et que vous
l'aimez
c'est possible énormément d'histoires
avec les combats de nos ancêtres
teixeira et je pense aux bonus et on
devoir se servir de sa puissance et sa
superbe au message qui je l'espère sera
entendu le riz merci beaucoup de nous
avons en parler de ton parcours
j'imagine que ce sera aussi une source
d'inspiration ont beaucoup de jeunes
martiniquais de jeunes filles
martiniquaise qui se donneront les
moyens les ambitions de rester ou de
partir un peu importe le choix mais en
tout cas de vivre leur rêve et de ne pas
se fixer de limite en disant je ne
pourrais pas parce que je viens d'une
petite commune je viens d'une petite île
mais oseront et en est la preuve vivante
on peut faire de grandes choses on peut
être en chine est responsable de voilà
dans une grande entreprise on est
vraiment fier on espère que tu vas
pouvoir repartir très vite ont retrouvé
ton activité professionnelle et on
espère surtout que là bas les conditions
le permettront surtout la chine
merci l'oreille pour cette belle
rencontre on est fiers de toi et je sais
que tu as eu aussi est particulièrement
fière de toi elle nous regarde là ce
soir j'imagine qu'à toute la famille et
tout le quart du qui doit être là en se
disant c'est une carte des siennes je
passe un petit salut un petit bonsoir ou
bonjour à des gens que tu connais vas-y
profites en super merci laurie encore
bravo à très bientôt
un parcours véritablement inspirant
celui de laurie dernière on espère que
tous ces jeunes qui parlent emmagasiner
de l'expérience reviendrons
aussi la partager en martinique et
seront demain nos responsables nos chefs
d'entreprise en tout cas c'est notre
souhait merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve très vite pour la
première